[Music]
hey what's up guys we are all thankful
for your support and being a part of our
family did a celestial emergence destroy
thanos home world titan or was it just
plain overpopulation
so what is the planet titan both in the
comics and the mcu
well in the comics titan was the moon of
saturn and was the home world of thanos
and his race of eternal skull titans it
is in fact situated in the solar system
whereas in the mcu titan was another
planet in a different star system light
years away from earth it was seen first
in infinity war when iron man and
spider-man stowed away on a spacecraft
in order to save doctor strange from
ebony mall it looked to be desolate and
had an orange huge atmosphere and loads
of destroyed infrastructure scattered
all over the surface
so who were the people living on that
planet well in the comics the titanians
were a tribe of eternals that inhabited
saturn's moon they were all exterminated
at the hands of thanos in the mcu not
much is known about the titans but they
were humanoid in looks and statue maybe
a bit bigger than humans the only talent
we know of is thanos and aerys thanos
whose purple complexion and superpowers
were due to the fact that he is an
eternal and has a deviant gene that
makes him different from the likes of
eros who is more or less like a human
and looks on stature and was also an
eternal station in titan
now let's just look at the mcu despite
the fact that thanos told the avengers
that the titans and their home world
were all struck with the situation of
dwindling resources and overpopulation
things might not be as simple as that
the story that we know of is this thanos
offered a solution to randomly kill off
half of the population to save tyrants
from extinction however his people
disregarded thanos genocidal proposal
calling him a madman subsequently
tyrants turned on each other for
survival which resulted in major
conflicts across the planet and the near
extinction of all tyrants with thanos
and his adoptive brother eros being the
only survivors but all this just doesn't
seem right it doesn't add up well with
arrows stating that he is in fact an
eternal and that thanos was won as well
so here's our take on the whole
confusion caused by the movie eternals
and how it aims to rectify the
existential paradox of the planet titan
and the people living in it well here's
the thing about extinction with a space
faring race that has very advanced
technology outright disappearance of
such a race due to lack of resources and
overpopulation is just outright lazy in
terms of story riding we can see that
thanos already has technology for
travelling interstellar space and the
fact that titans also had huge hovering
ships and infrastructure all over the
planet which means that they are at a
level of technology capable of faster
than light travel and capable of
colonizing nearby planets as well as
star systems if the need arises so
thanos didn't reveal the true nature of
the existential threat to his titan
people it was in fact that their
burgeoning population was bringing forth
a celestial emergence from their
homeworld something that would explain
an extinction level event
now let's take this as truth that
thailand was not only overpopulated but
also that this abundance of intelligent
life was feeding the celestial seed
within the planet at an alarming rate
that is why thanos who is an eternal
proposed wiping out half the population
so as to delay the emergence and
eventually finding another home world
for the people of that planet thanos
would have known about the true nature
of his existence this would have been
explained more properly in the deleted
scenes of eternals and their post-credit
scenes lines spoken by eros another
eternal from titan so now if this is in
fact the reality of the situation then
why didn't the emergence just destroy
the planet altogether like an exploding
bomb
well we will tell you why this isn't the
case
so here's the thing about celestial
emergence and that the planet is still
intact as we have seen in the movie
eternals when aresham explained to
cersei about their true purpose there
was a scene of the future termite
arising from the inside of the earth and
the whole planet just exposed boom this
looks horrendous but during his actual
emergence the sequence of events played
out in a very slow motion and wouldn't
have caused such a boom
of course the celestial coming out from
the interior will be a cataclysmic event
an extinction level event that will
decimate the surface of any planet and
those who survive the emergence will be
plagued by a rapid changing atmosphere
and the seas drying up due to the fact
that a hole has been created in the
surface of the planet right to the
mantle and even the core
and all that water would just vaporize
on contact with molten magma and the
core and this emergence would even tilt
the planet off from its axis as
described in the movie infinity war when
titan was said to be 8 degrees off
so what is the conclusion after all this
well if the emergence was just like that
of teamwork in the eternals then titan
did in fact face such a thing the fact
that the whole population died off or
was wiped off and that the entire planet
is off from its own axis like 8 degrees
off as well as having gravitational
anomalies does confirm our hypothesis
the entire surface does look desolate
and waterless a celestial hundreds of
kilometers tall coming out from a planet
might not destroy the entire planet but
will render conditions on that planet
unlivable so yes the fact that thanos an
eternal was concerned about
overpopulation does testify more to the
emergence of a celestial from titan
and while this might as well drive the
titan towards his ultimate goal to put a
stop to celestial birds by using the
infinity stones and wiping out half of
the population of the universe
and so i hope you have enjoyed watching
this video anyway with that we come to
the end of it so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family
and most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam